In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
Dear Jesus, may I enter into the eternal divine order of God to place my absolute nothingness
in the heart of the Most Holy Trinity, to give to my God the joy of fulfilling the purpose
of my existence by doing all the acts of my life through the immaculate heart of my mother,
Mary, and in the divine will of God.
And in this same manner, may I live, pray, act, eat, walk, sleep, and do everything.
May my soul be devoid of any other longings, wants or desires, and may you, my beloved
divine will, do with me whatever you want or desire.
All I ask is that you bind me to your most holy will so intimately, that I may never
swerve from carrying out what I know to be your good pleasure, and that I remain so docile
to the movements of your divine will, that you never perceive even a breath of resistance
in my soul to your requests of me.
Come divine will, with all the angels and saints, especially my sweet mother, Mary, to touch
my forehead, to imprint on it the Holy Spirit, and infuse in me true light, so that I may
understand the truths and the good that are in these writings and prayers, amen.
We have some very rich messages tonight, beginning at November the 19th, 1925.
And you see from the heading there that the divine will, wants the company of the creature.
The scriptures are quite clear about that.
If you go to Proverbs 8, 31, that the Lord wants the company of his children.
Okay, he delights to be with the children of men is the way it is put.
Okay, so we're going to be talking about keeping God company, which is really nice.
I felt as though immersed in the immense sea of the Supreme will, Louisa said, and I would
have wanted, as my beloved Jesus tells me, to let nothing escape me of all the act that
the divine will does, has done, does, and will do.
So there's your past, present, and future, which of course is all one in the divine will
because it's one act, which for Jesus are one single act.
And to be always with his divine will in order to give it my little requital of love and
thanksgiving, I call that our signature on the three feet.
I would have wanted to at least make a long note of all the acts of the Supreme will in
order to admire and praise what it can do and to be always with it and never leave it alone.
So Louisa is looking for the company of the divine will and the divine will is looking
for the company of Louisa.
But alas, my littleness is such that I get lost and I don't know from which point to
take the divine will in order to follow it because I find it everywhere and because in
the act of operating, surprising things both in the great and in the small things, Louisa
has the same experience as a fish in the ocean.
You tell the fish to go looking for water that don't work to begin.
It's everywhere.
If you tell the fish that there are limits to the Atlantic Ocean, that is incomprehensible
to a fish.
How do they know?
How would they get there?
How would they discover it?
So Louisa finds herself in the immense sea of the divine will and so it's a very easy
image to use.
So she doesn't know where to begin or finish.
I'm sure you've felt that as well.
But while I was thinking of this, Jesus came out from my interior and told me, "Daughter
of my holy will."
One who is daughter, that means you are truly united with the divine will, must know what
her father does.
She must know what he possesses.
Now in my book that should be a capital he and must be able to say to her, "Fathers,
what is yours is mine."
So this message and the one following it, the possession of God is what you're being told
is absolutely essential for truly living in the divine will.
So what is yours is mine?
This is possession.
If it is not so, it means that there isn't the highest accord between the father and
the daughter.
So we're talking about the level of divine union and the possession of God.
So if this isn't so, there isn't the highest accord between the father and the daughter
so that maybe she's not a legitimate daughter.
Wow.
He puts this huge question mark over it if she's not in true possession of God.
If she's not living in the highest accord, if there's not complete union of wills, I
can put it this way with my fingers.
You and me and I in you, both one, if that is not there then he says we might have to
put a question mark on your claim to be living the divine will.
Now he's not questioning Louisa in the divine will, this is a teaching for us and he uses
all her questions to teach the generations that will come after her.
In the same way, one who is a true daughter of my will must know what the divine will
does and the immense goods it possesses.
So then he begins to explain it.
Now to live in my will is precisely this.
To keep company with all the acts which my will does and that's precisely what Louisa
in the last paragraph said she wanted to do.
So Jesus is translating her desire to keep company with all the acts of the divine will
as the true living in the divine will.
My will doesn't want to live isolated in the midst of creation.
There's your Proverbs 8, 31 again.
It wants the company of the creature.
Now translate that into English.
It wants your company.
It wants my company.
Why is that?
It's because of the creature, because the divine will love her so much that the divine
will maintains the order of the whole of creation and makes itself the life of everything.
It's because of you, he keeps the whole thing going.
That's something that if you really sit with it, it will change you.
I mean what changed St. Paul was Jesus died for me, for me.
I know he died for everybody else, but he died for me.
So if we could really take it on board that the Lord has put the whole of creation together
there and holds it in order just for you, you begin to understand something of that divine
love and of the response that he requires from us.
And of course it must be a response of love that we give to him.
Now when the divine will finds a soul who keeps a company in this life that is on the
earth, I go to skip a tiny bit for a second, my will rejoices and it makes feasts, because
there's a repetition of the partial sentence there that maintains the whole universe because
of you.
So when the divine will find somebody who truly wants to keep it company, it goes into rejoicing.
It finds the one whom it loves.
Now you know God loves everybody.
God loves everything he has made.
So what do you mean finds the one that it loves?
You're talking about the one who will enter into its love more than anybody else, the one
who will respond more than anybody else to its love, and therefore the one who will receive
more than anybody else, this love that the divine will wants to pour out.
Because it's all about love, because God is love.
So if you think that responding to the divine will and living the divine will is all about
rules and regulations and things I have to do in prayers, I must say you haven't got it.
It's all about somebody responding in love to love.
It finds the one that it loves and by whom it is loved.
You see, the whole thing comes down to one circle.
God is love.
He created everything out of love.
Everything has been brought into being because of love.
And when the creature begins to give that love back to the creator, then the circle of love
is complete.
And if you're in the divine will in that circle of love, you can bring everybody else.
And that love can go out to every creature that ever lived and ever will live once the
circuit is complete.
So it's extremely important that the divine will find the one who will return love to
it.
So it finds the one that it loves and by whom it is loved in return.
It finds one to whom it can make itself known.
Now I don't have to tell you since probably 10 out of 10 of you are married.
So I don't have to tell you that when you begin to receive love and respond in love,
that that's when you come to know the other person.
So it's exactly the same in divine love because marriage is simply a pale image of the love
that comes to us from the creator.
So therefore if we are responding, if we are completing this circuit of love, the Lord
makes himself known.
Now these are little pointers by which you can check where you're at in this relationship
because it's all about relationship and it's all about journey into God.
It makes itself known and it also makes known what it possesses and it makes known its
own happiness as well.
It narrates to the soul the secrets of its volition.
Not only that, but it narrates its value and its surprising effects.
Now we're on the 18th volume of this narration, of this revelation of the divine will to a
soul who opened up and was most willing to keep company with the divine will on the earth.
But each one of us must enter in.
It's not enough to know its second hand.
So the divine will narrate its knowledge.
Now we're getting this knowledge through Luisa and through studying her volumes.
It narrates its knowledge, what it does, what it is so that it can make a donation of this
to the soul.
Now the Lord doesn't want us simply reading Luisa.
Or even those of you who are teaching these volumes that you're merely passing on information
from a book to somebody else's book, that's no help.
I remember back in the 60s when I was conferred with the science degree in Dublin, we got
a terrible shock from the president of the university who told us that in the days that
we had spent in the university that he had witnessed the death of education.
He said, "I saw information going from the notes of the lecturer to the notes of the student
without going through the heads of either."
That's not just the death of education, that's the death of the divine will's spirituality
as well.
If we're just simply reading stuff and taking notes from other people, what other people
have managed to grasp from these writings, and we're taking it all second hand, and none
of it is going through us, it's not being filtered through our personality and our character
and our experience and our lives.
If the gospel doesn't come out according to you, it isn't the gospel.
And so you've heard me say over and over down the years that the Lord wants an individual
response from each one of us, so that the sheer variety of his kingdom and of his love
and of the divine will can be experienced by people on the earth.
If you read the gospels of Matthew, Mark, Luke and John, they get an enormous variety
in the response that was given to the mystery of Christ.
Huge.
They took this mystery from completely different angles, and yet all four of them were right.
And so when this mystery comes through us as lived experience, it's going to be the gospel
of the divine will according to John, according to Mary, according to Amelda, according to
whatever your name is, and it must come that way, otherwise it's not authentic.
So as the divine will narrates its knowledge and what it does, it also makes a donation
of this to the soul.
So we have to open up more and more and more to receive.
More than a valid script, you see, it's not just notes, more than a valid script, it is
knowledge itself that has impressed in the soul.
So God has impressed divine knowledge on the soul.
That's what he's doing.
And therefore our reading and our study of these volumes has got to go into prayerful
meditation and asking the Lord to put this within us, make this a lived reality inside
of us, and not just a learned lesson.
So the Lord wants to impress divine knowledge.
And don't forget that when Isaiah in chapter 11 of his book gave us the gift of the Spirit,
he started with wisdom, understanding, counsel, fortitude, knowledge, piety, which is the
relationship with God and the fear of the Lord, which is the beginning of that relationship.
They were the characteristics of somebody actually in a relationship with God.
And so the study of these volumes gives us this knowledge.
The Holy Spirit is the only one who can give you understanding.
I can't give it to you.
I just give you the little bit that I understand.
So God impresses this and don't forget that with Louisa, what he did was he infused the
knowledge and he will do exactly the same thing for you.
He's not a respecter of persons.
And so he impresses this with infused knowledge into the soul with characters of light.
And therefore the soul has the possession of the goods and the knowledge that the divine
will actually contain.
So we have to become more and more and more filled with this absolutely extraordinary food.
So I have Jeremiah 31, 33 there that you would be taught by God himself, or how beautiful
it is to see the sanctity, the power and the immensity of my will dwell in the littleness
of the human will.
So here you have the creator of the universe looking in admiration at his divine will operating
in this tiny little creature that is upon the planet earth as distinct from all other planets
and all other galaxies.
He's looking at this miracle that is operating.
He's seeing a spark of himself because that's what he's putting into us.
He can only give us himself.
He doesn't have anything else.
And he does it for the soul who keeps it company and therefore he makes us like God.
This is going to be terribly important for the next message.
The divine will always wants to give, give, give, give you a sign of love.
Someone who loves, gives.
It never stops.
It wants to see the littleness of the creature, beautiful, rich and powerful.
So he is delighting in making us like himself.
And you can put Ephesians 210 beside that, that we are God's work of art created in
Christ Jesus.
So he makes us like himself.
He wants to keep this wonderful little jewel that he is adorning all the time.
He wants to keep it close to himself.
And he wants to be able to give to it always so that if we are to continue to be God's
little jewel, then he has to be working on us all the time.
He's the jeweler.
So there's nothing more beautiful, more gracious, more surprising than a soul who tries to follow
the acts of the will of our Creator.
Now he's telling us what it looks like from heaven, from earth it doesn't look anything.
From our own view it doesn't look anything either.
You often have Louisa saying, but you know, what difference is it making?
You're going to hear that in the next message.
There's a continuous contest between them, a reciprocal love.
So the Creator is giving to the creature.
The creature is responding to the Creator and the more she responds, the more Creator
gives and the more she responds and it goes on and on and love becomes greater and greater.
And the circle of love becomes wider and wider and wider to include absolutely everything
and everyone.
If you only knew how rich you are, Jesus said to Louisa, as many things as you know about
my will, these are goods that you possess.
Now notice you have to know to possess.
That means that you've taken it out of the book and you've put it in here and you've
gone further and you've put it into your heart and you've gone further and you've allowed
the Lord to put it into your spirit so that it really becomes you.
This is the new you that the Lord is creating all the time.
As many things as you know, you possess.
And if you could enumerate them, he said you'd get lost and you would remain drowned within
them.
In other words, Louisa has no idea about the vastness of the riches that she actually
contains because she is the first to live the divine will after our blessed mother.
Then she must contain graces for all those who will follow.
So let's come to November 22, 1925.
The great good that the soul has by living in the divine will.
So Louisa says, "I was fusing myself in the holy divine volition according to my usual
way, trying as much as possible for me to embrace everything on my little lap.
In order to place my little, I love you, my thank you, my adoration, my bless you upon
all things."
So here she is putting a hark signature on all that God has done.
She does it in creation and in redemption.
And she does it in order to keep company with the supreme will.
So you can see that this is following on from what we've just said.
So as to keep company with the supreme will, which is spread in the whole of creation with
so much love because love is the origin of everything.
But while I was doing this, I thought to myself, "What does the soul receive by doing
all this?"
I love this thing now, and I think that the Lord put that thought into our head because
it would be what we would think rather than Louisa.
You know, "Okay, I'm doing all of this, but what good do I get out of it?"
And the answer that the Lord gives her here is very profound and it's very rich and it
will take more than one reading.
I'll only give you one reading, but you have to do all the other readings yourself.
I've had to do the readings before this.
So what good does the soul receive by living in this celestial atmosphere of the divine
will?
In other words, what's in it for me?
At that moment, beloved Jesus came out from within my interior and clasping me all to
himself, he told me, "Now this is number one in the answer.
My daughter, do you want to know what the soul receives in living in the divine will?"
Now, if you have a pencil and paper, it would help.
Okay, number one, because there's going to be at least eight pieces.
Number one, she receives the union of the supreme will with hers.
That's the very first thing you receive union with God.
Now before Louisa came on the earth, St. John of the Cross said, "Reaching union with God
was the highest experience a human being could have on the earth, your canonizable."
In these writings, union with God is the starting point.
And you move on from there, because this is a divine holiness.
This isn't just ordinary holiness that reaches union with God.
You come into union with God and you go on.
My will takes on the task of giving parity with itself.
Now I stumbled over that word, went to the dictionary, and parity means equality of rank,
got that out of the dictionary, unless they've mis-translated it.
In other words, the Lord wants to bring each one of us to a divine level, to operate on
a divine level.
Is there anything about that in scripture?
And of course the answer is yes.
And Sam 8, 2 verses, is it 4 or 6?
I wrote it down somewhere, but I can't see it now.
I said, "You are God's, all of you sons of the Most High."
Sam 8, "Lord, you have made us little less than a God, with glory and honor you crowned
us."
The church teaches that Jesus became man in order to divinise us.
Well, to divinise us means to operate on the divine level.
And it's just when I saw the word parity, I said, "My goodness, this is incredible."
It's just when it's put in another way, it hits you harder.
So in this union, not outside of the union, my will takes on the task of giving parity
with itself to the will of the soul.
That's where all decisions are made.
So my will is holy, my will is pure, nothing else is mixed in with it, my will is light.
Therefore in this experience, we have to become holy, we have to become pure and we have to
be transformed into light.
That is, if we are to have parity, if this union is to be a reality, if we're to be able
to live on this divine level, if we're to even persevere with this relationship because
it was the prophet Amos who said, "How can two walk together unless they're alike?"
People who have married the wrong partner knows to their utter pain and distress that
two people who are not alike can't walk together.
If there's nothing there for union, you can't do it.
And so Jesus said, "My will is holy, it's pure, and it's light, and it wants the soul
equal to itself in holiness, purity, and light equal to him."
That requires a proper transformation or shall I use the word transfiguration.
And if the task of the soul is to live in my will, my task is to give my likeness to the
will in a perfect way.
Therefore you will know if you're living in the divine will because there will be constant
transformation happening inside of you.
If there's no transformation happening inside of you that you're aware of, then you need
to turn to the Lord and well, my way of saying it is do business with him to make sure that
we actually get into this level of relationship.
So he wants to bring us step by step into likeness with him because Saint John says that when
we see him, we will be like him when we see him as he really is, that's in John's first
letter, chapter 3.
So this transformation was God's will forever.
He just had to wait until the human race was ready to move in this direction.
And this is why I want you always in my will so that it may not only keep you in its company,
but that it may make you grow in its likeness.
Now there's two things here, one is that you keep company with the divine will.
So that means a creature on earth is keeping company with God in heaven.
But since you become one, then God in heaven is keeping company with the creature on earth.
And through every person living in the divine will, God is living on the earth.
That's how he reaches out to transform the rest of them.
And he wants you to grow in this likeness.
Now again, I just want to underline that if we're not growing, there's something amiss.
We have to be growing in this likeness, okay?
So and this is why I feed you with the food of the knowledge of the divine will.
In other words, to grow in divine likeness, you need to be fed with divine food.
Now divine food is scripture.
It is the Holy Eucharist and it is prayer and it's what is revealed here from Jesus himself
through Louisa.
So we have to feed on this.
This is why we cannot at any point give off the study of the volumes.
And this is why I feed you on the food of the knowledge of the divine will to make you grow
in a divine manner.
Now, if you feed on earthly things, you grow on an earthly way.
Feed on divine things, you grow in a divine way and you will feed with its perfect likeness.
And it's for this reason that my will, once you always with itself, wherever it operates,
that it may give you the act of its operating and give you the value which the operating
in the divine will contains.
So tiny summary, what are we to receive?
Number one, we receive union with God.
Number two, we receive likeness to God.
Number three, we have to grow in purity, holiness, light, wisdom, knowledge and possession of
God.
That's a tall order.
So that we become equal with God.
We have this parody with God.
That means we have the same characteristics.
And the task of God is to carry out this miracle inside of us.
And our task is to stay with him and keep cooperating with him all the time, because
this is what he wants to do for all human beings to make us sons of God.
So in the next paragraph, Louisa responds to him and she says, "I have what your divine
will is in everything."
And it's in everyone.
Otherwise, they wouldn't exist.
So why aren't they all transformed?
Very important question and the answer that Jesus gives is very revealing.
So Louisa said, "My love, your will is everywhere, and everyone lives in it, but not everyone
receives your likeness."
Jesus immediately said, "What's that going to do with anything?"
It's true that all live in my will, because there's now a point in which my will is not
present.
But watch this now.
This is frightening.
But almost all live in the divine will as foreigners or as mercenaries, which is even worse
that's using it, others by force, because they can't get away from it, others as rebels.
Oh, dear.
These are all the reactions that human wills give to God.
Some people become God haters.
Some people become atheists.
They want to throw out the idea that God exists at all.
So let's bring in something here that you mightn't think of unless it's said, and then
you say, "Well, that's obvious, yeah."
If you go back to the book of Genesis, Satan brought down the human race by telling them,
"Yeah, I know you're supposed to be like God, but you'll become like God if you know
good and evil."
Now, God hadn't intended the human race to know the evil.
Evil doesn't do you any good, and knowing evil doesn't do you any good.
Just try the modern world, and so the lie that the human race swallowed from the very
beginning was, "If we know good and evil, we will be like God."
And Jesus is telling us here that to know God, you don't need any evil.
Evil and Satan are the lie that you've got to be pushed aside.
But those who are living in the divine will as foreigners and mercenaries and people living
in it by force or as rebels, they've believed the lie.
They think they can have good and evil and be like God's upon the earth.
Because that's what Satan said, "You will be like God if you know both, but you cannot
be like God if you know evil," because evil comes from Satan.
We grow in the divine will by growing on divine food, okay?
And we all know that you become what you eat.
So if we're feeding on evil stuff, you become that.
That's what you see the tragedy in society today, people feeding on pornography, destroying
themselves absolutely.
That's just taking one example.
You become what you feed on, and so if you feed on divine food, the divine life is fed
in you and you can reach the level that the Lord wants you to reach, okay?
So this is why Jesus wants us always in his divine will so that he can bring about this
incredible transformation in us and that he can give us the value of operating in the
divine will on a divine level in a divine way, it's really, really fantastic.
So the people who have the divine will inside of them, but they're living as strangers and
foreigners or rebels, watch what Jesus says because you learn about the unity he's just
been speaking about by looking at this.
He said, these people who are living as mercenaries and foreigners and as rebels and so on, they
live in the divine will because you can't do anything without God actually permitting
it, but they don't know God, they don't know the divine will and they don't know the goods
that the divine will actually wants to give.
On the contrary, they are the usurpers of that very life which they have received from
the divine will.
I think they have us from the divine will and Jesus calls them usurpers because they're
using God's will, denying God or fighting God and this is the result.
Each act of these souls is a dissimilarity that they acquire between their will and that
of the Creator.
So each divine act that we do in the divine will brings about the similarity and the
parity with the divine will.
Every act that is in total rebellion as has been described here brings about a dissimilarity
and a gulf between the divine will and us.
Okay.
And this confirms them in their poverty.
Now this is talking about spiritual poverty, they could be billionaires but we're not talking
about material things, we're talking about spiritual poverty.
It confirms them in their passions, in other words they're following their instincts, they're
following their hormones, they're not following God's will.
And it confirms them in tick darkness, a very good description of society today.
The tick darkness in which they find themselves in such a way that they are blind to all that
is in heaven or all that is heaven.
Now all of us know that there are very few people today to whom you could talk on the
level of spirit, they would think you're off your head.
Only those living on the level of spirit can speak the level.
So Jesus says that this rebellion and misuse of the divine will actually leads to a terrible
gulf, unfortunately if the person dies that way, the gulf remains.
In order to reach the parity with my will, which is the opposite now, one cannot live
like a foreigner, one has to be the owner, that means you are living with the possession
of God.
You are actually one with God, your will and God's will are one, therefore you have the
possession of God and therefore you are the owner, Lord what is yours is mine, what is
mine is yours.
One must look at all things as one's own and have the care for them.
Now the people who are living a natural life and wanting to keep God and religion out of
the public domain are the very ones telling us about environmentalism and looking after
Mother Earth, but it's Gaia, it's the goddess Mother Earth and the Pachamama idols that
goes with it, the symbol of Mother Earth.
That's not it, that's not what the Lord is talking about.
The people who truly are in union with God are the ones who take care of the whole earth
in love because in the divine will each one of us embraces the whole earth and we embrace
all creatures and we pray for them all and we intercede for them all and make reparation
for them all and substitute for them all and we are doing everything we can to actually
bring them back to God, we are the ones caring for the earth, but the others wouldn't see
that because they don't have that kind of care.
So it's truly the saints who look after the church and the world, therefore it's necessary
to know them in order to love them and possess them.
So you have to, it's only in the divine will that you come to the true appreciation of
the wonder of creation and the wonder of redemption and the three fiats and as you enter more and
more and more deeply into them then your appreciation turns into intercession and reparation and
all the rest of it so that you put your signature on the three fiats of God.
So we must know them in order to love them and possess them as beautiful and good as something
may be if it's not really your own you don't really care for it, that's what he's saying
in this next little bit that you really have to own something to really take care of it.
For example, you may love all children on the planet, but as a child happens to be yours,
if the child came out of the miracle of birth from your body, that's a different matter,
totally different.
The different subject, that's what Jesus is saying here, that we need ownership of the
divine will to have ownership of the whole earth and all of creation.
Now Louisa has reached that point, it is the person who went through, oh yeah, so he says
that if you don't own something, you don't really care for it, but if you own it, you
care for it and he says owning it makes a huge difference in us.
The value of the thing doesn't change, it is you change in your relationship with that
and that's where coming into union with God, the change is in us in the way we respond
to God and we respond to God's creation and everything he has done.
So let's come to the next paragraph then, and we're talking about possession of the
divine will.
This is what the soul receives in living in my will.
She receives the divine will as her own possession.
She possesses it and she feels its celestial aura, now here's another little way of checking
where you're at in the divine will.
She feels its celestial aura, in other words, this isn't just theory in your head.
You actually know this in your experience.
She feels the life of heaven and the likeness of the one who created her and as she lives
in my will, she feels studded with the reflections of her creator.
There were absolutely inundated with all this grace and blessing and glory.
In everything, she feels the power of that fiat which gives life to all things.
Now notice the words in everything.
This union with God is 24/7/365, it's not something you do for a day or a week.
In everything, she feels the power of the fiat which gives life to all things and in
the sea of goods in which she possesses, she says how happy I am, the will of God is mine,
I possess it and I love it.
Look at the power you have spiritually, if you can say the will of God is mine, I possess
it.
Try and imagine the power you have.
Try and imagine the power of your prayer.
Therefore, all the acts done in my will diffuse over everybody and everything.
Everybody takes part in them.
So what do you call loving your neighbor when nearly eight billion people benefit from
your prayers?
See when at daybreak you were saying may my mind rise in the Supreme will in order to
cover all the intelligences of creatures with your will so that all may rise in it and in
the name of all I give you the adoration, love and submission of all created intelligences.
While you were saying this Jesus said a celestial dew poured out upon all creatures covering
them and giving their acquital of your act to everyone.
Oh how beautiful it was to see all creatures covered with this celestial dew which my will
formed symbolized by the dew of the night which can be found in the morning over all
plants to envelop them, to fertilize them and to prevent those which are about to wither
from drying up.
With this celestial touch it seems to place a touch of life in order to make them vegetate.
Now notice Jesus is comparing this prayer in which you ask the Lord let all wills rise
in the divine will.
He compares that to the the morning dew that is on plants.
Now the morning dew on plants isn't as critical for us who live in the northern regions as
it is for those in the tropics and in very hot regions because it can mean the difference
between the life and death of the plant and it's the dew that can keep the whole harvest
alive for example and if the dew doesn't come then the harvest could be destroyed in the
terrible dry heat so it's a touch of life and what Jesus said to Louis is that when we
pray like this a touch of life is given to every single person.
Just think about it it's magnificent.
Touch of life in order to enable in the dew to enable the plants to vegetate human beings
enable them to revive.
How enchanting is the dew a daybreak Jesus said.
How much more enchanting and beautiful is the dew of the acts which the soul forms in
my will.
So the more acts we do the more we enable everybody else on the planet to rise and come
back to God.
Louis isn't taking it hands down so she says okay yet my love she said with all these two
creatures don't change.
She's speaking in 1925 when the world is in turmoil and the leaders are building up for
a second world war so it certainly doesn't look as if people are improving and the disaster
of what happened in the Soviet Union is there for everybody to see and the frightful persecution
of the and destruction of the church in the Soviet Union is there for everybody to see.
The terrible gulags have been opened and the millions of martyrs are beginning to appear.
So she says they don't change you know and so Jesus says if the night dew does not does
so much good to the plants it will unless it falls on dry wood separate from the plants
or upon things that don't have life such that even though they remain covered with dew and
somehow embellished the dews as though dead to them and as the sun rises little by little
it just simply withdraws.
Much more good does the dew which my will this sentence is upside down my will does much
more good when it descends upon souls sorry I try to give that in English.
Unless they're completely dead to grace very interesting.
In other words this dew of their prayers in the divine will is offered to absolutely everybody
but if it lands on a soul that's dead to grace it's not going to do anything.
And yet by the vivifying power that the divine will possesses even if they are dead it tries
to infuse a breath of life into them you see as long as a person is not actually physically
dead there is hope and so even for the worst sinners on the planet there is still hope
that this dew will actually give them life.
But all the others he said some receive more some receive less according to their dispositions
and we know that about absolutely everything we know about the grace that people receive
and the sacrament it all depends on a person's dispositions or their openness to God.
Let's turn to December the sixth we're nearly up to date now in December 1925 so Jesus continues
the same message.
Louisa said I was doing in my interior my usual acts in the supreme volition embracing
all creation at all creatures in order to make all their acts my own and requite my God with
my little love for everything he has done in creation and for everything that all creatures
should do.
So here she is trying to make up for everybody but while I was doing this a thought came
to me you take so much time in doing this and what's the good of it now again this is
a question that we would ask I'm spending hours at this thing I mean you know am I just
saying words as any value what is the glory that you could give to your God she said at
that moment Jesus answered her of course he stretched out his arms and he seemed to want
to embrace everyone and everything then raising them up he offered everything to his celestial
father and then he said to me my daughter the true living in the supreme will is precisely
this I must find everything and everyone in the depth of the soul you see the union with
the divine will is a universal relationship it excludes nobody it's a love and a life
that goes out to everyone it's one of the things I absolutely love about this it's love
without borders so living in the divine will is precisely this I must find everything and
everyone in the depth of the soul everything that my will has issued in creation for the
good of creatures must be bound in the soul with her love you take them all and you covered
them all with your love and with your blessing with your thanksgiving with your praise and
so on they must all be bound in the soul with her love by living in my will and by her
required love love she's already bound to and in possession of all that my will has done
and will do so once we're in union with the divine will we're in possession of everything
God has done is doing and will do of course it's all one act in eternity but in time it
seems past present and future and she loves as my will loves that is love without borders
and she loves is my will can love I love that text in Philippians 4 19 where Paul is thanking
a group for help they have given him and he says that I pray that God will reward you
as only God can in a divine way so the soul in possession of the divine will loves as the
divine will loves and can't love so this is the parity he's talking about so given all
this by her living truly in the divine will and having bound everything to herself I find
in the soul the starry heavens the refulgent son the vastness of the seas the prairies
of flowers I find everything in her therefore is it not right that the soul hopping from
one thing to another over all that is mine and hers that she would recognize it and that
playing upon all created things that she would impress on each one of them her kiss and her
little I love you so there's that beautiful exercise that I call the butterfly you hop
one to the other so she puts her her kiss and her little I love you for the one who has
created so many things to give them to creatures as gifts displaying to man by this a variety
of love for as many things as he created well the sounds are quite clear about this that
of only human beings would really genuinely look at creation they'd have to believe in
God and yet I have been in places on the earth like Norway that are absolutely magnificent
beyond compare and practically no faith don't understand because all the scenery there would
just make you burst into praise so God has just displayed his love in an absolutely variety
of ways in the creation and you would look at how he loves that man would be happy giving
him not only what is necessary but also the surplus God gives everything he has made sure
that everything is there for us but this isn't everything not only must I find the whole of
creation but the true living of my will binds everyone and therefore I must find in the
soul as though in act Adam holy as he came out of my creative hands as well as Adam guilty
humiliated and crying so that she may bind herself to him in the state of sanctity that's
number one and taking part in his innocent and holy acts she may give me glory and we
make the whole of creation smile again and then secondly she will join Adam in his tears
she will share his tears and with him she may long for that they fiat that he rejected
which I'd call so much ruin thirdly I must find in her the profits the patriarchs the
holy fathers with all of their acts this is in the first advent when they were longing
for the redeemer and you will long in the second advent for my fiat sanctity they triumph
and fulfillment of absolutely everything so here the lord is actually giving examples
of what you should embrace and in case you would sort of gloss over things he's saying
no no no I want you to go down through all these steps in other words you keep the whole
history of the Old Testament and the New Testament alive and you keep on blessing them and putting
your acts of love on them and your gratitude what you're looking for the divine will to
descend to the earth because the long for redeemer has come so then number four I want you to
find my inseparable mother and all of her acts in which my will operated so many portents
of grace having full dominion and I want you to find all of myself and all of my acts in
some I want to find all my things all that belongs to me all that my supreme will has
done and will do and because these are all things which are inseparable from me therefore
if you're living in the divine will it should be inseparable from you all these things
are inseparable from me and it's just and it's necessary that they become inseparable
from the one who lives in my will what is mine is yours what is yours is mine so if I
don't find everything it cannot be said that she lives completely in my divine will look
at the word completely and in looking at her I don't find all of my things but I see them
scattered outside of the soul and I cannot receive her quite love love for all that belongs
to me have I perhaps not created the creature so that she may be a little world and a little
God so there you have Sam 82 verse 6 again I said you are gods all of you sons of the
most high and Jesus quoted that in John 10 34 I said you are gods so this is why I always
say to you that living in my will is not yet known it's not understood it's not grasped
we're studying it and I wonder how many of us could really say I know it I live it and
I keep teaching you one thing and then another and I expand your capacity so that all my things
and all the good which my will has issued may enter into now there's a prayer that needs
to be said quite frequently and that is Lord open my soul open my heart open my mind open
my whole being for what you are revealing to me and increase the capacity of my soul
to receive it I want to hear you repeat to me Jesus said you're a quite love love in
everything that belongs to me that's the three fifths I don't tolerate for one who lives
in my will not to know all my things and not to love them and possess them otherwise what
would be the great priority of living in my will if you weren't participating in everything
after this my sweet Jesus remains silent and I wandered into the divine will I love the
way she gets a revelation and she immediately obeys oh how I would have wanted to place
my loving and grateful kiss upon all created things and my little I love you on all the
supreme acts of the divine volition so to remain bound I to them and they to me to be able
to surround my Jesus in me with all the acts of the eternal will as the last bit of that
sentence I want to underline so why does she want to do it she knows Jesus is living within
her she knows she's in this inseparable union with him and so what she wants to do
is to surround Jesus in herself with all of these acts that's absolutely magnificent so
she wants to build his throne more and more and more in herself therefore the kingdom
of the divine will is therefore growing more and more and more in herself that's the bit
we have to pick up I just think it's wonderful at that moment Louisa said I saw the starry
heavens and my beloved Jesus resumed his teaching my daughter he said look out at the heavens
what order what harmony among the stars is a great lesson here now even if you're an astronomer
one star can't be without the other each one is the strength of the other that this
is what human beings in the church don't seem to grasp that we actually need each other
that none of us can be what they call in Gregorian chant an isolated pumtum a little
note all by yourself we actually need each other we need the support of each other we
need the gifts that each one has we need the response that other people give to God to
enable us all to persevere and keep going and to strengthen the whole group all the
stars need each other each one sustains the other each one is the strength of the other
and if even a single star moved from its place there would be so much confusion and disorder
in the atmosphere now with the disintegration that we're looking at in society today you
can see that human beings are not supporting each other they're not looking out for each
other they're not enabling the other to develop and he said that if even a single star moved
from its place and there would be danger of everything ending up in ruin the society
has ended up in ruin so all the beauty of the heavens lies in the stars remaining each
one in its place in the common union and in the communicative and attractive force which
they have among themselves and which more than electricity keeps them suspended and
bound to each other wonderful wonderful wonderful statement there he says all the beauty of
the heavens is when everything remains in the divine order all the beauty of the church
is when every part of the mystical body of Christ is in the divine order the beauty of
the earth is when everything is in its place in the divine order but you will have noticed
since the last century that everything is going out of order women want to be like men
men want to be like women just to give one example married people want to separate priests
want to be married it's the old things upside down people are not staying in the order in
which they were put but if they would remain in the order in which they were put everybody
would grow and everybody would be strengthened and so I'm going to read on a little bit and
go to finish this is that's okay in the next paragraph Jesus says man or human the human
race is the new heaven and you know in the Old Testament the promise was there was going
to be new heavens and a new earth and many have not understood that this was the transformation
of redemption that was going to come so man is the new heaven more than the heavens above
the earth it can be said that each creature is an animated star now please underline that
if it's if it's your own book Daniel 12 3 Daniel said that the people of God were the
stars in God's heaven and you met this in the book of Revelation in chapter 12 when Satan
pulled one third of the stars from the sky which is a great apostasy okay so each creature
is an animated star so he's saying that all of us together are new heavens so what you
see over your head in the planets and in the stars if only we could see ourselves as the
Lord sees us he sees us in a pattern like that as well so each creature is an animated star
that which the first man Adam did up to the last one who will come everything was to
be in common among them no wonder the instinct has been in the church from the very beginning
to live in community everything was meant to be assured so man was to possess not his
own strength by himself but the strength of all were strong with all of us together so
we were not meant to be loners all goods were meant to be held in common so you could see
that the instinct of the church to live in community has been right my will more than electricity
was to bring the bond between them and the communication of all that is good and holy
because the binding of the human race was to be the divine will all of them living in
the divine will and therefore nobody needing to be higher than anybody else nobody needing
to be special nobody needing to stand out everybody supporting everybody else that's
the new Jerusalem in Revelation 21 and 2 and even though each man was to do his own office
and occupy himself with different actions in other with their different vocations since
all were to be start from the primary point of my will all would be converted into light
so you would see marriage in all its beauty you'd see singleness in all its beauty you'd
see priesthood in all its beauty just to take three examples all were to be converted into
light and therefore each one was to be light for the other and that's absolutely beautiful
so there's your Matthew 514 letter light shine therefore my sorrow in seeing the heaven
of creatures messed up was so great as to be incomprehensible to them well I don't
understand that once my will was removed which binds everyone and links everything what did
you get disorder confusion disunion weakness and darkness that's what we have in abundance
on the earth today poor heaven of creatures it can no longer be recognized and only the
living in my will will reorder this heaven again so here's another point that's extremely
important for us and a pointer towards growth and that is am I allowing the Lord to reorder
me according to his will if I'm in a family am I allowing the Lord to reorder that family
if I'm in a community am I allowing the Lord to reorder that community everything around
me as well as in me must be reordered according to the divine will otherwise the transformation
can't happen and only the living in my will will reorder this heaven again and will make
it shine with new light this is why I tell you that I want to find everyone and everything
in you my will the primary act of all celestial and terrestrial creatures will bring you the
communication of all of their acts now all the angels are living this way and so when we
move into this divine order we move into the angelic order as well and all of their acts
in the heavens are available to us and you will remain bound to them and they to you because
we've entered into this divine order so the living in my will encloses everything and
everyone therefore be attentive but I want to give you the greatest thing that exists
and I want from you great things in return to him who has received more more is expected
that's Luke 1248 and so I wanted to finish that for you because next week is our last
class and I didn't want to leave it over until then so thank you for joining us and God bless
you.